the having kids part is not something that holds me back dating
it's just it's like
the biggest thing that holds me back dating
is finding somebody that can match my energy
you just meet a lot of people that are looking for another mom and you're like
okay yeah
no no
I'm not definitely not into that
I've got my own children
like the children
for as much as people like to blah blah
blah talk shit on the internet
no there's not um
a shortage of men that are willing to line up for literally any woman
so the issue isn't gonna be finding a partner
it's gonna be finding a partner that you want to date
so you just have to maintain your boundaries
maintain um
like your like
figure out the type of person you're looking for
actually like
become that person
you know be the type of person you wanna hang out with yourself
be the kind of person that you
you like and you're gonna attract somebody like that
and then it'll be easier to kinda sort through
you know you're gonna start to surround people with that energy
but when you're like